in season three of the Mandalorian din
jarin bathes in the Living Waters to
restore his status as Mandalorian but
his Devotion to his clan means fans
don't get a view of everyone's favorite
internet daddy spoilers ahead although
there are different factions of
Mandalorian people the one that din
jarin belongs to is stringent when it
comes to honoring the old ways of the
mandalorians this means that Jaron is
expressly forbidden from removing his
helmet in front of any living being for
doing so would mean expulsion and
excommunication from his clan however
Jaron does publicly remove his helmet a
few times throughout the Mandalorian
either to say goodbye to his adopted
child or to save his own life because of
these transgressions Jaron is forced to
bathe in the Living Waters on the ruined
Mandalorian home planet to be readmitted
to his clan Mando achieves this goal and
it seems as if he has taken his renewed
vows very seriously jarin is never seen
without his helmet throughout season 3
of the Mandalorian but to the dismay of
fans taking the social media some fans
lamented that they weren't given a
chance to see Jaron without his helmet
with one user tweeting din took his
helmet off twice in season two because
he knew that tin can was staying on for
season three many others agreed when it
came to wanting Jaron to take his helmet
off at least once on Twitter a user
posted an image of Kermit the Frog
rousing nooses and expressed tremendous
disappointment at not being able to see
jaron's face likewise one user wanted to
see Jaron as well and said that his
helmet could have at least fallen off
during one of the many fights throughout
season three these sentiments were also
echoed over on Reddit where a redditor
started a conversation by pointing out
that this was the first time Jaron
hadn't taken off his helmet for an
entire season this statement caused
several to reply with some saying yeah
he should have had the helmet off at the
very end just in the background I
thought they only took it off around
family would have sold that even better
others agreed with that sentiment
thinking that it would have been a nice
touch to solidify grogu and jar and his
family Let It Be written in song The din
jarin is accepting this foundling as his
son another redditor had their own
Theory as to why jarrin never revealed
his face this season they thought he
remained covered because Pedro Pascal
could only do The Voice work since he
was also appearing in HBO's The Last of
Us even though many would love to see
jar in space his spoken Creed as a
Mandalorian prevents him from doing so
but most fans understand why it wasn't
an option for him in season three as a
Twitter user pointed out the Mandalorian
takes his religion and culture seriously
and he isn't going to risk being exiled
again this is especially true after
having to go through so much effort to
redeem himself another user agreed it
explaining that the Bounty Hunter went
to Mandalore for a reason elsewhere some
fans on social media believe that jaran
keeping his helmet on in the season
finale actually made his enemies seem
less evil the Twitter user wrote I was
waiting for them to take Den's helmet
off to humiliate him when he was
captured but I guess moff Gideon isn't
as vile as I expected him to be in short
for Jarren to show his face in public
again he'll need to be captured by a
truly evil foe who not only wants to
defeat him but also wants to humiliate
him if no villain is willing to sink
that low then it would take an event so
Monumental that Den is willing to risk
his status within the children of the
watch to show his face once again